To code the unconnected function,
we used functions of
the location request object.
First of these was setInterval.
Now, this sets the desired interval for
active location updates measured
as a period in milliseconds.
So right now, if it's set for
a thousand milliseconds,
that means it will check
the location once every second.
That's pretty fast.
So, if you wanted to change that
to be less frequent, for example,
once every ten seconds,
you could just change this to 10,000.
Remember, it's always
measured in milliseconds.
Then we use set priority.
This is used to set the priority of
the call, as it's name might suggest.
The priority is a strong
hint to the location client
about which location
services it should use.
There are many factors about which
physical devices it will use,
such as the available
hardware on the phone.
It has four potential values,
so let's take a look at these.
This one that I'm showing,
PRIORITY_BALANCED_POWER_ACCURACY,
will give you accuracy
to about 100 meters.
It's nicknamed block level accuracy for
obvious reasons.
It's course, and very battery friendly
compared to some of the others.
PRIORITY_HIGH_ACCURACY will give
the finest possible location,
based on phone hardware.
But, as you can imagine, this could
impact your battery much more.
PRIORITY_LOW_POWER will request what
is nicknamed city level activity.
It gives you a range of
about ten kilometers.
It's a very low power
consumption activity.
And finally,
PRIORITY_NO_POWER will request the best
possible accuracy at no power cost.
So if other clients in the app
have gotten a location,
this can actually be
a passive listener to them.
Do note, that if you have set the access
course location in the Android Manifest,
it will override these settings, and
can effectively reduce the frequency of
location poles,
as well as obvious gating it's accuracy.